i [ __ ] hate the amish man i [ __ ]
hate him like i truly hate him
is he not is he from san diego where are
you from you're like a surfing ass
dude huh pennsylvania apart they have a
gay part of pennsylvania
[Applause]
huh lancaster y'all left the a off that
[ __ ] too
i hate that [ __ ] county man get some
electricity
you got these [ __ ] pilgrims walking
around with a horse
[ __ ] you huh
you wore amish you were too sexy for
that
you don't [ __ ] huh much [ __ ] to be
amish
get out of here they're over there
raping their family members because
they're ugly as [ __ ]
act like i don't know about the amish i
don't actually but my girl watched a
reality show and told me about it
you awesome raping ads you probably got
[ __ ] in the ass by a lot of uncles you
pretty [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] hey
you didn't just build wood you had wood
installed
[Laughter]
my man was the tabletop
oh [ __ ] i can't believe you're amish bro
i've never met a good looking amish in
my life
you got normal looking teeth
[ __ ] man all right so why did your
parents leave this [ __ ] weird ass
community this mutant
community you guys have it is a cult
right you guys are acting like i can't
insult the amish
you don't know any amish they don't talk
to you
they can't make it here from lancaster
or whatever [ __ ] there's a two-week
trip on their horse and buggy
[ __ ] losers
stopping traffic with a [ __ ] horse
and carry this ain't central park
[ __ ]
it's a street it's a real ass street
you sitting here yeah [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] hate him huh
if your car sounds like this
[ __ ] you you're not a human being
you willingly drive a [ __ ] horse and
carriage
god damn grow up man speak english
i swear to god if i if i just
confidently was like yeah yeah the
the amish they speak you know aramaic or
some made up a [ __ ]
language you'd be like oh okay i guess
because you've never spoken to an amish
person
you're the closest you ever come to an
amish person is you buy their [ __ ]
pancakes at redding terminal
and you just look at the uncover the
amount of butter they put on it
and you're like this has probably got to
be good right i don't know
using that much butter [ __ ] wearing
bonnets at reading terminal throw up
why are you coming to a costume place at
a costume party
kind of weird thanksgiving role play are
you guys doing
all year i [ __ ] hate the amish man
i [ __ ] hate him like i truly hate him
like i didn't realize i hated him that's
like i was talking about it but i
[ __ ] hate the amish
he would [ __ ] you you don't want to use
technology
what the [ __ ] is that go to a different
country then
don't be in the most technologically
advanced country in the [ __ ] world
how stupid you look and now i gotta work
around your dumb ass
lancaster or lancaster whatever [ __ ] you
call it
stupid-ass [ __ ] village or
shire or whatever the [ __ ] turn to use
i hate these people pancakes are
delicious but everything else can go
give me the pancakes and the oatmeal
outside of a couple breakfast foods [ __ ]
the amish
and you know it's great i can put this
bit online they're not gonna comment
they don't even know it exists
you [ __ ] losers your [ __ ]
bums you [ __ ]
a bunch of rapist incest [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
somebody said let them know they don't
they can't they can't watch it
[ __ ] losers oh
man all right so when did you leave the
community how old were you
i was 10 years old 10 years old so you
got [ __ ] for sure
my man i couldn't i can't get past all
the kids [ __ ] you know it's a thing
it's a thing you guys are like the
crystalia of the religious community
oh man what's up guys thanks for
watching the video if you're a fan just
hit subscribe stop hating what are you
waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming up
[Music]
you